All right.
What's going on people.
I am caffeinated and ready to roll.
So we were going to do this at
7:00 PM Pacific tonight. Uh,
but then some scheduling things happen.
I literally just landed from
Philadelphia this morning, uh,
Boston two days ago.
The Toronto,
the day before that just landed in
la a we're taping too shows today.
I'm not going to reveal everything right
now. One of the guesses a little late.
So we thought we'd do this now,
maxing out at the time here. Uh, I,
I have so many things that I
want to share with you guys.
There is so much good stuff
happening right now. Uh,
this tour with Jordan Peterson has been
amazing. Uh, my return to stand up,
there's so many signs and signals that
the things that we're talking about here
are,
are really taking root.
I think that this a intellectual dark
web article from Barry Weiss in the New
York Times two weeks ago really,
really leveled this thing up.
And it's just reached
all across everything.
And it wouldn't even be just that.
It's the good part of the article
that reached across everything.
It's that the amount of hysteria and
angry people and misrepresentations of all
of our views and all that,
the amount of articles being written
about it and think pieces and all this
nonsense. It's like, man,
we must be doing something right over
here that all these people are just making
up this nonsense and to be on tour
with Jordan Peterson where literally
literally every day there is another
ridiculous hit piece written about him
often.
I've met the author of the piece,
The New York Times when they came out this
week about his enforced monogamy idea.
I was in the green room on the first night
of the tour, I believe in Toronto, uh,
two weeks ago, uh, with, with the girl who
wrote the piece. And it's just like, man,
journalism is freaking dying and dead.
And by the way, with that in mind,
we're getting some new
allies in this space.
Alon Musk has been on a freaking
tear about mainstream media. Um,
so I think there's a lot of
interesting things happen.
The Dalai Lama tweeted something
about individualism, uh,
and coming together as people.
I think there's so much cool stuff
happening right now. I'm totally enthused.
I'm meeting literally thousands of
you guys. Uh, you know, these events,
most of the theaters that we're doing
are about three to 5,000 people.
I think the biggest one we did
was the Apollo in, uh, London,
which was 5,000 people.
I mean, think about that.
5,000 people coming to hear a
psychologist talk about ideas,
you know, it's just awesome.
So I usually go up there,
I do about 10 to 15 minutes to stand up.
I get the crowd grown,
we're talking about lobsters and cleaning
your room and all this crazy stuff.
And I just get everybody
having a good time. And,
and the beauty is you can feel it
that for you watching this right now,
for most people watching this stuff,
it's like you're watching
this most likely on your,
on your phone or you're on a computer.
It's a pretty singular experience, right?
Maybe with somebody, but usually you're
not watching it. A whole group of people,
although I have heard that now some
students are watching the show and there's
some, uh, groups.
There's a group in India that I think
gets together on Sunday nights and watches
my show. It's amazing. Uh,
but generally speaking,
you're watching this as a solo
experience and you're kind of just,
we're doing this right.
Um,
but to be in a room with
5,000 people who agree,
disagree, black, white, gay,
straight, all of that stuff,
all of that diversity, uh, but are just
coming together to hear about ideas.
And then here Jordan talk
about why racism is not good,
why the alt right is bad,
why cultural Marxism and
progressivism are also bad.
And just everybody getting on board
talking about personal responsibility is
just, it really, I feel like my
life, even from two weeks ago,
my life has changed because you can't be
around that kind of force for that long
and not feel something.
It just,
it feels real and honest
and good and I think we're,
we're challenging each other.
Jordan has made it very clear that
nothing is off limits during the Q and a.
So usually I take some questions
from the crowd, uh, that they there.
There's an APP that they
send questions in on,
but then I mix it up with
some of my own stuff.
He's challenged me a little bit
on some things. It's been a,
it's been a total learning
experience. I'm very cool. All right,
so here's what we're going to do here.
Uh,
so on top of the Jordan Peterson tour,
which I'm heading back out on,
our next stop is in Houston and in Dallas.
And then Austin,
we're doing a little Texas thing
starting in a couple of days,
but I am here for a couple of days.
Uh,
we're booking some standup stuff for
me around some of the tour stuff.
So I've got three shows that
I want to tell you guys about.
And for anyone that buys
a ticket during this with,
you're watching this right now
and you're one of the first, uh,
we're gonna do this for 20 people
at each one of these venues. Uh,
we've got DC coming up, we've
got Tempe, Arizona, and we've
got Seattle. Am I right?
Yes.
Okay.
If you are watching this and you're one
of the first 20 people to buy a ticket
to the show and the links are right
down below. While you're watching this,
we're going to let you into the,
to the meet and greet.
I do a meet and greet afterwards,
shake hands, say hi, take pictures,
all that good stuff. Uh, we'll,
we'll let you get in that for free.
There's a premium charge for that,
but we'll do it for free. So, uh,
the links to the show or right down below,
it's a Tempe, Arizona, the Tempe Improv,
uh, that is on June. Uh, Tempe
is June 3rd. Uh, so that's,
that's basically next week. Uh,
we got the DC Improv on June 7th,
and uh, the Seattle, uh, we're going
to be at the parlor live in Seattle.
That's on June 20th. So what you do
is if you buy a ticket, screenshot it,
send it to contact@rubenreport.com.
We're going to get you in on the meet
and greet after contact@rubenreport.com.
Just send your,
you're a screenshot that you bought
some tickets and we'll get you in.
We'll say hi,
we'll do all that good stuff.
Maybe I'll go out and hang out and
have drinks after. I don't know.
We'll see what, what's going
on. Um, okay. You know what?
I was supposed to say 10 people per, but
I said [inaudible], I'm a man of my word.
All right guys, it's 20 per
20 per show. So there's 60,
60 slots if you happened to be near
DC or Seattle or a Tempe, Arizona,
which is right by Phoenix where I'll
be with Jordan in a couple of days. Um,
so anyway, so I'm just, I'm
just as you can tell them,
I'm just psyched about what's going
on here. Um, these shows we were in,
we were in London last week, 5,000
people at the Apollo theater. Uh,
it was just incredible.
I got out.
So usually the way these theaters working
or these are huge, awesome old school,
you know, Phantom of the opera theater
is just beautiful, beautiful buildings,
most of them. And they usually have like
an artist entrance or something. Uh,
but for the one in London, I didn't
know where the artist entrance was.
So my Uber just dropped me off right
in front. There were out there,
2000 people outside. I got
stormed. I mean, it was crazy.
Like the amount of people that are
so excited about this stuff and,
and everyone talking about their
political awakening and the same shit that
you're thinking about that I talk about
here, about what it's like to, to, uh,
evolve politically and realize that you
were wrong about some things and want to
learn more. And everyone has like
an amazing life story to tell me.
And people always,
they want to give us stuff.
Everyone wants to give Jordan personal
written notes or some people have done
some incredible artwork and stuff
like that. Like it's just been,
it's been so cool.
But as I said before,
it's that it's that everyone's coming
together and people are looking around and
going, Whoa, you're, you're a Jordan
Peterson, a fan. You, oh, you know,
Dave Rubin, like, it's just
like, it's like real, it
really feels like real, real,
real and cool. All right. Let's see.
So I'm going to take a couple
of questions by the way.
So we're going to do the super chat thing.
If you're watching right
now on the youtube,
we're doing super chat real quick on
youtube. I don't know if you saw this,
I guess they announced this yesterday.
I tweeted about it today,
but they're going to be,
they're experimenting with changing the
feed because we really want more of that
sort of thing where they're going to,
they're going to sort of rejigger your
feed to figure out what you might want to
watch instead of showing you
stuff in chronological order.
Now call me a conspiracy theorist,
but if they don't really like the stuff
that the content creator is putting out
there, it seems that they might, uh,
just hurt you in everyone else's feed.
Everyone wants just a chronological feed,
right?
You subscribe to things because you know,
you like them. And if you don't want,
if they put up a clip that you don't like,
if I put up an interview that you
don't like, you don't watch it.
But we don't need youtube or any more
of these algorithms to do more or hiding
things from us or promoting other things.
And we know that there's just so many
ways that that can be manipulated as,
but they're experimenting that right now.
And by the way,
I'm not asking the government to come in
and fix the problem. I'm using my voice,
my free speech. I see this on Twitter
all the time. People will say, see Ruben,
your,
you don't want any regulation.
You don't want the government
to come in and fix anything.
Well now look what happened with you tube
and the NFL and blah, blah blah. And No,
I don't want the government to
come in and fix these things.
I don't think the
government can fix youtube.
I don't think the government can
fix the NFL or anything else.
The government can't do that much,
especially the federal government
as it certainly can't do it well or
efficiently.
Uh,
so what you can do and what is your right
and duty as an American is to use your
voice to express pleasure or displeasure
or whatever it else with any company.
So when I tweet about Youtube
People's, ah, you see,
you don't want the government of
all, so you can't whine about it. No,
that's the whole point. You
should complain. So that
hopefully someone up there,
some of the higher ups go,
Whoa know there's a bunch of creators out
there and it's not just me by the way,
uh,
that are complaining and these guys
seem to have some influence and they're
using our platform. Maybe we should think
about what our decision making is here.
That's what you do in a free society.
I can't,
nobody's forcing me to
be on Youtube, right? Uh,
and they don't have to
let me be on youtube,
but as long as they're
letting me be on youtube,
I can use my voice to affect the platform.
And that's exactly what you guys can
do. And by the way, one day, I assume,
and I have reason to believe that there's
plenty of competition coming down the
pike. Don't want to say too
much, you know what I mean?
But I just think there's opportunity
and competition and capitalism.
That's the answer to all of these
problems. All right, so here we go. Uh,
reminder though, you guys should click
that bell on the subscription thing.
If you click the bell and I think
it'll give you a couple of options,
like how much you want to be notified.
That way you hopefully,
if they're not manipulating
this thing too much,
you'll see the videos and all
that. That, that being said,
our subscriber growth has exploded in
the last month. Every now and again,
suddenly we see these odd anomalies and
then I contact them and they say, oh,
nothing's going on, but people
keep telling me there'll
be an unsubscribed, blah,
blah, blah. It's a bunch
of insider stuff. Okay.
Reminder one more time and then I'm
going to dive into some questions.
Any of you guys that are watching
this either live or, uh, or after,
depending on how many people jump in.
Uh,
we have 20 slots at each of the three
shows in Seattle and Tempe and in DC.
And if you screenshot your tickets that
you purchase while you are watching this,
uh, we will let you in to the meet
and greet after absolutely free.
They charge extra for that,
but we'll do it for free and I'll
say Heidi and all that good stuff.
The links to the shows are down below.
I've only done one hour long show so far.
It was the Irvine Improv couple of weeks
ago. Uh, it was, it was awesome. I,
I give you my word.
The,
the manager came up to me after she said
that was the first sold out standing
ovation. She had seen in 18 years of
working there. I'm not making this up. Um,
by the way, I may, it's a
little unclear right now.
Perhaps there will be a guest or two
from the intellectual dark web that will
join me on these, uh, on these
shows. But I do about, you know,
an hour and then I do some live Q and
a fiddle around if you guys will. All,
all kinds of fun stuff. It's great to just
get back to my old life of doing that.
It's, it's completely different than what
you guys know of me sort of doing the
interview thing. Uh, I'm also working on
the book again because I'd been signing,
because people come up
to me after the shows.
They want me to sign something
and they all have Jordan's book.
So I've been signing Jordan's book, which
seems unjust. Um, so I finally just,
cause I've been so busy it's, it's been
put on the back burner a little bit, uh,
finally really dove back into
it the last couple of days.
So we're working on that too. A
lot of good stuff happening. Okay.
A superchat patrion questions.
Let's do a little something.
What's an example of a view that
you've been challenged on? Well,
I think the one that everyone knows the
most, uh, is from, uh, last week's guest,
Larry elder.
Although this happened about two and a
half years ago when we were talking about
systemic racism way back when.
And that's when I still considered
myself sort of more part of the left or
progressive or whatever
you want to call it. Uh,
I was kind of just waking up
to a lot of that stuff and, uh,
and Larry just beat me senseless.
There are many clips of this.
I think on Youtube, one of the clips,
someone just took our clip straight up,
which we're fine with it. It
hasn't had a million views, uh,
of Larry just beating me.
That systemic racism,
meaning the laws that are built
into the system doesn't exist.
It doesn't mean that racism doesn't exist.
There are always going to be racists.
They are going to be bigots.
They're going to be people that don't
like black people and people that don't
like gay people and everything and
people who don't like white people and
everything else. Uh, but you can't,
you can't change everyone in a society.
And if you want to change
everyone to decide of,
you're probably a pretty
bad person actually. Uh,
but what you can do is make sure that
all the laws are equal so that everyone
has equal opportunity,
equality of opportunity.
You can't get to where we're going to
have equal outcomes because some people
are going to be more talented,
some people are going to work harder,
some people are going to be luckier.
Uh,
but you want equal
opportunity for everybody.
And I would say that the way
that you would deal with,
so people always say, well,
all right, well what about some historic
injustices and all that sort of thing?
Well then I would want education to be
focused on let's get it down to the state
level and let's make it slimmer
and trimmer and use money
better. And not, not, uh,
you know,
pour so much money into federal programs
that don't really work and having
everybody,
uh,
just learn so that they can pass the test
without actually learning and all that
stuff.
Uh,
so education I think is where you can
make a lot of movement if you want to get
people to be more actually equal but
watch. But Larry doing that, I think,
you know,
I've always said it's,
it was sort of the best moment and worst
moment of my career at the same time.
It was the worst moment because I went
into a conversation. I'm not ready,
not armed.
So when I said this thing about systemic
racism and he turned it back on me,
I was kind of like a deer in headlights.
So it was my worst moment for that,
but it was my best moment because
we let it be. I, you know,
I've told this many times,
Germany, you guys know this,
but we were at aura TV at
the time. We go into the, um,
the control we might after
the show and there was,
we had a bigger staff at the time and
one of the producers who said to me,
you know, you guys got to cut that
from the show. And I said, no,
we've got to leave that, that is a
human moment. That is a real moment.
I don't mind being wrong.
I don't mind being humbled and I don't
mind being shown up actually when it's
done the right way.
You know what I mean?
I don't want to be belittled
or attacked or something,
but he wasn't attacking me.
He was attacking my ideas
and my ideas were shaky.
So I think it was a good
lesson for me and I,
and I've heard from literally
hundreds if not thousands of you guys,
that it was a good lesson
for you guys as well. Uh, oh.
Where can you get this Hoodie?
This is the Rubin report and this is
the official Rubin Report Hoodie. Uh,
you can get the hoodie@rubenreport.com
slash. Shop. I'm correct.
It's shopped.store,
I believe it is Rubin report.com/shop.
We got, we got hoodies,
we got tee shirts, we got
cutoffs store it, store Rubin,
report.com/store. I've been,
I've been freaking busy people.
I'm bouncing around the world here. I'm
a busy, it's Rubin report.com/store.
Uh, and we got all kinds of stuff over
there and there. There's some cool stuff.
We got classical liberal tee
shirts, libertarian ish, um, and,
and a whole bunch of other stuff.
Uh, it's a great way of uh,
supporting us a little bit and uh,
and you know,
spread and worried about what you're
doing. A okay, quick reminder.
The three shows are a Tempe Improv,
June 3rd DC Improv,
June 7th,
and Seattle at Parlor live on June 20th.
Any of you watching this first
20 at any of those things?
If you buy a ticket to any of those shows,
the links right down below,
we will get you into the
meet and greet for free.
If you email us the ticket stub.
So we see you that you actually bought
the ticket@contactatrubenreport.com.
Uh, how's am I doing? Am a dog.
Many of you guys know Emma.
She gets in some of my behind the
scenes videos every now and again. Uh,
have Emma will be 14.
Uh,
what's Today is today the 22nd is today,
the 22nd guys.
She will be 14 on June 22nd.
Uh,
she's a rescue from New Orleans,
from Hurricane Katrina.
She's just the greatest
dog in the world. Uh, and,
and still spry for a way at 14. What do
you like a 95 year old dog or something?
Uh, yeah, she's, she's great.
Thanks for asking. Um, uh,
someone on Facebook. Are
you? Hi. No, I'm not. I'm a,
I had been drinking a lot of coffee,
uh,
because it's hard to be on all
these flights. And you know,
last week when I came back from a London,
we had to tape a couple of shows like
that morning and I was way jet lag.
I didn't sleep on a 10 hour
flight for some reason. Uh,
so my caffeine levels are up.
Are you noticing a higher energy?
Is that what's going on here? No, I am
not high. And, and even if I was high,
I mean, I've mentioned this before,
I don't smoke weed that often,
maybe once or twice a week.
And I like indigo, which is,
that's the one that takes you down.
I don't need to be high to be more
in my head, you know what I mean?
I don't need any of these doors open more.
I would close a couple of them if,
if possible. Uh, so I,
I do like a hit of Endeca 11 o'clock
at night and I watched the Simpsons or
Seinfeld and go to sleep. So No, I'm
not high. I promise you. Okay. Uh,
let's see, uh, from Facebook,
any chance of continuing the founding
fathers slash historic figures series?
Yeah. So first off, I was so
thrilled that so many of you, uh,
like that as much as I did
where we did a president's week,
five different presidents with five
different scholars in five days and learn
liberty, uh, helped us produce that. I
just loved every second of it. I mean,
you guys know, I just love
that. Actually speaking of that,
I was in Philadelphia yesterday. I went
to the Liberty Bell, went to Constitution,
uh, center. I just love all
of that history. I loved
those documents. We just got,
you know, we'll post it on, um,
on Twitter right after it's,
and we'll post it on Facebook as well. Uh,
when I was at a turning point event, uh,
last month, there's a guy that
gives that prints these giant, uh,
prints of the declaration of
independence and the constitution.
So he sent them to us and we just
put them up in the green room.
So now we've got a massive old vintage
American flag and we've got those up
there. Uh, it's, it's all very
cool. Um, but I just love that.
I love history. I didn't, you know, I've
always loved history, but I think this,
you guys learning about this stuff,
I'm learning right with Ya.
So I loved that week. I love
being in Philadelphia. I
love when I go to DC and I,
you know, go to all the monuments and
all that stuff. Um, so yes, we're,
we're trying to figure out something
else we can do with learn liberty in that
vein. Uh, but for sure we'll do
more of those. And also I just,
to me it's like people are too upset
and obsessed more than upset there too
obsessed with the day to day
machinations of politics,
what a leak happened at the White House.
And this happened and that happened and
it's like, this isn't news, you know,
last night. So I saw an old
buddy of mine from college, Mike,
if you're watching this, I'm giving
you a live shout out. My friend Mike,
by the way, great guy. He wants
beat. We were sophomores in college.
He beat Super Mario Brothers,
I think in nine minutes and 47 seconds.
If you max warp to level four,
Max warp to eight and you plow
right through a eight three,
which I think is a tough one. Uh, yeah.
And then you've got to figure
out the Dungeon on eight four.
He beat it nine minutes and 40 some
odd seconds. Uh, anyway, great guy.
So I saw him last night and uh, he, uh,
I went out with him and some other people
and we were sitting at the hotel bar
and they had a huge, a
television screen, like not even,
it was like a huge wall of TVs
basically for four huge TVs on a,
on a big wall.
It's many screens and CNN was on one
and MSNBC was on the other or whatever,
like a ticker was on another one.
And I think the sports thing was
on the other and I was facing them.
So they were looking at me and I have
the TV kind of over over their shoulders
and I, I was just, I never watched that
crap anymore and he just seemed so dumb.
At one point I got up,
I was like,
I can't sit here anymore because I
keep being distracted by this dribble.
Another headline that Trump
is and it's just nothing.
So we actually switched seats.
Then they were bothered by it and then
we actually just shifted around all
together. Um, okay. Here we go. Let's see.
How long are you planning on doing the
Rubin report? That's a good question.
I mean, you know, it's
funny, I say this to a,
to a mirror until Alexis and to David and,
and to tell you all the time,
it's like I, we're just the
beginning again, it's crazy,
but like everything that we've worked for,
everything that we've talked about,
the conversations we're having,
it all fuels more relevant, right?
This very second than it's ever felt.
So I have no plans of doing anything else.
I've been meeting with a whole slew of
people about all kinds of other different
projects that I can be involved
with do on the side. I mean on,
people are reaching out to me with
all kinds of, uh, interesting offers.
I can't get into all of them right now
or I really can't get it to any of them
because you don't talk about
shit until the pain is dry. Um,
but I love doing this.
I really love doing this and I feel I
just feel more validated than ever while
doing it.
And it's great and I hope that I'll keep
getting better and all that good stuff.
Okay, here we go. What are
we doing here today? Uh,
we're talking about the Peterson tour,
which has just been,
just been spectacular and I'm so any
of you that are watching right now,
I hope I've met some of you out there.
It's just been great.
Just saying hi to people and people
from every walk of life and every age in
sexuality and color and all of that stuff,
and,
and high school people and people in the,
in their senior years and everything in
between. It's been so cool. Uh, but yes,
I'm busting out the standup.
It's coming back.
People hour plus in my standup plus
perhaps some intellectual dark web guests.
Uh, June 3rd Tempe Improv links right
down below June 7th at the DC Improv link
right down below Seattle Parlor live
June 20th link right down below the first
20 of you at each one of those venues
who buys a ticket while you're watching
this, even if it's late, even
if you're not watching live,
if 20 of you have not done it yet, you
can still get in on this. Uh, we'll,
we'll upgrade you to the
meet and greet after, uh,
where I come and hang out with you guys
and take pictures and all that good
stuff. Uh, so you've just got to buy
the ticket at the link down below,
screenshot it,
contact@rubenreport.com.
Just send it to us and we'll take good
care carrier. Uh, okay, so we've got,
we've got VIP spots available
for you guys. All right,
let's see what's going on here.
Hey Dave, as a classical liberal,
what do you think about the NFL requiring
players to stand for the national
anthem? Is this a free speech issue
or an employee rights issue? Okay,
so I got into this today, uh, with David
from on Twitter. Uh, and by the way,
I invited him to come back on the show.
Uh, he's in La next week, but I'm on tour,
so I think we're going to do
it in October. That's when
he said he'll be back on.
But we had a little bit of a,
he compared this to the James DeMaurice
situation at Google and it's nothing
like the James Demora situation.
James Dimauro was invited to go to these
diversity training things and then told
afterwards to share his thoughts,
which he then did with Google.
Then they punished him
for sharing his thoughts.
They fired him for his political beliefs
and for doing exactly what they told
him to do.
And by the way,
it was just two or three months after
he had just gotten a promotion. Um,
this is not that case. No one has
been fired. Tap Renick was not hired.
He was a free agent. He wasn't hired
by any team, but he wasn't fired.
And you have to understand that these
things are all businesses. So let's,
let me just try to do this as
cleanly and clearly as possible.
And as Jordan says, every night, uh,
you have to be very precise with your
language. I am a free speech absolutist.
You can say whatever you want within the
constructs of the few things that under
the law you are not allowed to do.
So you can not make a direct threat.
I'm going to kill you. I'm going
to kill all of those people, right?
I'm going to blow up that.
You can't do that.
You can't yell fire in a crowded theater.
There's public safety issues.
And then we have extremely,
extremely specific,
very hard to prove libel laws.
Okay?
Which I believe in
actually because you can't,
especially nowadays with the
amount of just evil, noxious,
toxic journalism out there. And
social media and all that. Uh,
if you, you have to have some
protection around that. By the way,
these laws are virtually never used.
Um, and I believe they should exist.
But with those exceptions, you can say
whatever you, you're allowed to be mean.
You're allowed to say bad things, you're
allowed to upset people, etc. Etc.
You're allowed to say things
about protected groups.
You can't say we're going to kill him,
but you're allowed to say mean things.
I would prefer you didn't, I would prefer
everyone be real nice to each other.
Right? And that's what conversation's all
about. That's my feeling on free speech.
Okay. So that's one thing. Now, if,
if you watch the video that I did,
uh,
and I tweeted it out today so you can
find it on the NFL protests from seven
months ago, I stand by
everything that I said. You know,
everyone was treating this thing like
there was this massive assault on free
speech and that,
um,
that the government was stopping people
from speaking and all of this stuff.
So let's,
let's try to do it cleanly here.
The players can do what they want, right?
The players can either Neil or not.
This is, I'm getting up to
the point of yesterday, right?
Or I guess it happened today with the,
the new regulations that
they're going to have.
So we're just going back seven months.
At that point,
the players could do whatever you
want. You could kneel or not, Neil,
you can express yourself however you want.
The team then can do whatever it wants.
It can either find you are
not fine, you or um, you know,
put out a statement saying
they agree with you or not.
The owners can do whatever
they want with their business.
The League can do whatever it wants.
The president,
although I would prefer that Trump not
gotten involved in this in the first
place. He can say whatever he
wants. Now, he called the players,
I think he called the players
sons of bitches or something.
That's fricking ridiculous and
awful and he shouldn't do that.
But he is entitled to his free speech as
well. Even, even when at that level it's,
it's a pretty gross thing that he said,
but everyone's free speech in
this instance was x was respected.
Everyone was allowed to
do whatever they want.
Now that doesn't mean you aren't
gonna suffer repercussions.
So let's say at the end of the day an
owner looks and they go, you know what?
We've got these players kneeling.
Now we see our audience is turning against
us because our audience doesn't want
that. We see our TV ratings
dropping, we see attendance dropping.
Um, we see merchandise not selling
as well. While I'm in a business,
I'm a business owner, I own a
team. They own a team for a reason.
You're allowed to then not hire people.
You're allowed to fire people. I mean,
this again, this has nothing to do with
the government. So this was actually,
even though it all felt weird,
it was government working.
Now if Trump or the government or
any state official or whatever it is,
would have used coercion of the
government to say, you have to stand.
Of course people, of course I
would be absolutely against that.
But they did not do that.
Now what happened yesterday
or it was earlier today, I'm,
I've been traveling so much,
I'm a little unclear, uh,
is that it sounds like what they're going
to do is if you don't want to come out,
if you're a player and you don't want
to come out for the national anthem,
they're just going to ask you to
stay in the locker room. That's a Oh,
the league making its decision and the
players now can choose whether to abide
by that or not.
And if they don't abide by it and they
go out there and they meal and the League
has said, you cannot do that, well then
they're going to suffer the repercussions.
They are 100% as far as I could
tell from everything I read today.
You could spend the other six days of
the weekend and 21 some odd hours minus
the three hours that you're on the field
playing football. You can be protesting,
you can be tweeting, you can
do whatever you want. Um,
but the league has a right to say what
standards are just as youtube, by the way,
has a right to do whatever
it wants. Again, I mean,
I think I started this off by saying
that these companies can do whatever they
want.
The idea that the government can come
in and either fix them or tell them what
to do is just something that I
just simply don't believe in.
And I've never heard a compelling
argument for it. And by the way,
I know that I disagree with this on some
people that I absolutely respect. Um,
so my basic feeling,
so your question was how would a
classical liberal feel about this?
I'm in a classical liberal, basically,
you believe in laissez faire economics.
You want a very light if at all, touch
of the government on these decisions.
So as long as no one's rights
were infringed on, no one,
no one was stopped from speaking.
In other words, if you're, if, look,
I have a business here, right?
Let's say, uh, tomorrow, uh,
a mirror came in here and said,
you know,
for the first half hour that I'm
working every day I'm going to protest
something and I'm going to stand here
with a picket fence and I'm going to,
you know, the picket sign
and blah, blah, blah. Well, I
might be like, you know what,
you have a right to do that. You have
a right to express your free speech,
of course, but you can't do it on
my dime. Does anyone think that?
Me As a small businessman,
I would have to hire someone that
wasn't working the entire time,
the entire time that I was there doing
the expectations which I've set forth?
I don't think so. So again,
this is where freedom is messy.
It doesn't all feel good.
I don't want people to have to be left
in the locker room and all of all the
underlying reasons that they're doing
this protest in the first place. Uh,
but everyone in this case is allowed to
make their choice. The owners, the league,
the players, the fans, everyone is
expressing themselves accordingly.
And if you're not happy with the
League did, then don't watch.
And if you are happy then
do watch and buy stuff.
So he got to let freedom ring.
You've got to let it ring.
That's what I think about that.
Okay.
Are you staying on the Diet while
on the tour? I basically am.
It's been obviously a little bit tough
and I did have a cheese steak while I was
in Philly. I wasn't going to go to
Philly and not have a cheese steak. Uh,
but yeah, I've been doing it. And
uh, so since we started this thing,
which was a little bit,
I think it was right into the beginning,
first week of January of this
year, uh, I'm down about 20 pounds.
I'm going to try to go for about five
more. I know I don't really need it,
but it's like once you start,
you're like feeling real good and you,
you look in the mirror and
you see those differences. Uh,
and I just feel good in general. I
think really getting, getting sugar out.
So I'm doing this sort of slow carb,
Paleo thing, very, very low car.
But mostly just meat and fish and
vegetables really got sugar out more than
anything else and I feel good.
I feel clean. I feel clear.
I feel lighter for sure.
Uh,
so I'm going to just keep trying do it
and then I guess at some point when I get
to some magic number,
then I just got to figure out how to,
how to kind of balance it out. All
right. We got about 20, 20 minutes here.
What are we doing here?
People?
I got three stand up events come in and
I want you to come back stage for no
extra charge. Okay. That was
my best. I became a uh, 1980s,
a salesman right there. Um, Tempe Improv,
June 3rd DC and June 7th,
Seattle at the parlor live.
If you buy a ticket right now and you're
one of the first 20 people at any of
those events at any of
those specific locations,
screenshot it right now.
Screenshot that you bought the tickets,
send it to contact@rubenreport.com and
we're going to let you in the meet and
greet for free. I'll say, Heidi, I'll
give you a high five. We'll take a selfie,
all that good stuff. And we're doing
that for 20 people per event. Okay,
here we go.
Dig in the art in the background.
So we got a lot of compliments on the art.
So there's this blue one here,
right there. Uh, that's
Kaitlyn rose. Janet,
who's done a bunch of artwork in
my house and she did the paint,
the painting that's on the
other side of the guests.
A lot of people see that say that they
see Kurt Cobain in there. You see,
I can kind of see it like there's an I
and there is an eye and there's the nose
and a mouth over there. Yeah.
Um, uh, so that's that. Um,
I always forget who did a, who did this,
oops. I always forget who did the, uh,
that one right there. A mirror knows
we'll, we'll post it in the comments. Um,
yeah, it's, uh, I like having good art.
We may do some refreshing around here and,
and change a few things as time goes
by. But uh, yeah, there you go. Um,
let's see. Um, can you tell us who
the bad actors are specifically?
I'm not sure what you're referring to.
I do talk about bad actors often,
but I don't know what you're
specifically talking about in general.
When I talk about bad actors,
I'm talking about people that are
just misquoting people, intentionally.
People who are doing clickbait titles,
whether it's on youtube or on a, you
know, just print, whatever it is.
People who are just lying about
what other people are saying.
People more than anything else. People
who are talking about people all the time.
I mean, think about what I've
done here for the last hour.
I've talked about ideas. I don't care
about talking about specific people,
even Trump that much. I would much rather
talk about the underlying ideas, the, uh,
the fact that there are so
many journalists who wake
up in the morning and they
were like,
today I'm going to get Rubin or I'm going
to get Sam Harris or I'm going to get
Jordan Peterson or anybody.
And it's like,
if you think that we're the
biggest problem out there, you're,
you're a little misguided
in what you're doing. Um,
so I don't like talking about people and
if your goal everyday is to talk about
people and attack people and, and smear
in Lyons slander and all that stuff,
I just don't think you're a good
actor in this space. And when I,
when I say this space, I mean just in
the space of people talking about ideas,
I'm not perfect. I'm not always right.
Uh, but if you are acting in good faith,
then I'm, then I'm happy
to talk to you. Um, okay.
Let's see what else is going on here.
Is Mike Pence a Cyborg?
Um, there's, he's a little robotic.
There is no doubt that the guy's a
little stiff. Uh, so I think it's,
I'd say there he's key. Could be 10%
robot. Is Hillary Clinton a lizard?
I possibly, uh, both cannot be true.
Well, anything's possible. Good question.
Good question. Um, okay.
Let's see. Um, all right,
what else do I want to tell you?
I'm going to let a couple,
a couple of other questions, a load in
here on, on Patriot and super jet. Um,
you know, bouncing around this
thing and go into all these cities.
What also has been nice about it just
in the last couple of weeks beyond,
beyond doing London, which was
great. Oh, I spoke at a Oxford Union,
which hopefully the video will be
up on their channel in a day or two.
It was just wonderful. Uh, so Oxford
Union, it's in, it's in Oxford,
which is about an hour away from London.
And I didn't realize this,
but it's a small collection of colleges.
Some of the colleges are very small.
I think someone's gonna be one of the
colleges is like 14 people and then some
guy, some of hundreds, et cetera.
And it's in this really great,
quaint old town that you kind of
feel like you're in Harry Potter. Uh,
and it really is one of the last bastions
of free speech at the academic level.
Uh,
and it was just wonderful.
So what we did was they were probably
about diabetes. It was standing room only.
I don't know, maybe about 200 students
there. Uh, the president of Oxford Union,
a lovely young lady. Uh,
she asked me questions.
I didn't know anything in advance. They,
you, they let you do it however you want.
So she said,
you know,
I could give an opening statement and
then we could do a Q and a and then we'll
take questions from the crowd.
She could ask me questions,
interviewing me however you want
to do it. I said, you know what,
I'm so used to being on this side of
the interview. Let me just sit down.
I don't need to make an opening statement.
Just start asking me whatever you think.
She asked some pretty challenging
questions right from beat one.
And the audience asked spectacular
questions and challenge me on some stuff.
And it was a true joy. Every second
of it, uh, was a joy. And then I, uh,
had a drink with,
uh,
with some of the students after and
it was like all of these kids again,
and I hate having to say this,
but I think it's important
because of all the smear pieces,
the diversity of color and ethnicity
and background and religion and all and,
and sexuality and all that stuff.
It's all there.
And stop thinking that people's
ideas are based on those things.
What a sad way to live, you
know, in a sad way to live. Uh,
it was just great. A super chat, mate. I
love what you're about. Thank you mate.
And I love your love. So thank you
very much for that. Um, yeah, so, uh,
so London, but then, uh,
we get back to the states and just in
the last couple of days, as I said,
we did Boston. We did Philly, we did
Toronto, we did Denver, we did, uh,
we're doing Texas bunch of
SOPs in Texas. We did. Oh Man,
we've been all over the place.
Like it's actually,
it's hard for me to even like
categorize exactly where we've been,
but what's been nice is that each,
we did San Francisco.
What's nice is that each city is
its own thing. We did Seattle.
It's like you can really get a
flavor for each thing. So the,
so the shows that I've enjoyed the most
so far, uh, San Francisco is spectacular.
Uh, because I brought up Eric Weinstein
as a surprise. So I did about 10 minutes,
get the crowd's going crazy. And
then I was like, you know what,
here's another member of the ID.
I bring out Eric Weinstein.
He plays the harmonica, he goes up there,
plays the harmonica for about a minute,
3000 people applauding.
And it was like, man,
I go backstage with him after and it's
like this guy is so accomplished in
mathematics and economics and you know,
he works with Peter Teal and it was like
the true joy on this guy's face that he
got to play the harmonica for
3000 people in that they loved it.
It was just so awesome.
What I found is that the cities that
lean a little more left, so a Seattle,
San Francisco for example,
that's where the crowds had
been the hottest because I
think because they're the
outliers there, they come
and they're like, holy cow,
we're here with other people kind of
think like us. So it's very exciting. Um,
but, but really all of the
shows have been good. They,
they're all sort of different.
Philly last night it was a little more of
a working class crowd. You can tell. Uh,
but it's great and people are coming,
they get dressed up,
people are wearing suits.
Um, and, and, and, you know,
girls are wearing dresses. It's just,
it really, it's just great. It's just,
it's just been a true joy.
All right. Couple of other
things here. Um, let's see.
Do you still open,
you're open yourself to having your mind
changed as the intellectual dark web
gains momentum. How do you
make sure you're not becoming
dogmatic and your views?
I mean,
all I can do is constantly
be open to ideas and,
and see where the best ones fall. I
don't think there's any, you know,
that's really the beauty
of this thing. I, you know,
I saw some of the hit pieces on this
where they tried to frame us as a mostly
white male group. Now first off, we
all just happened to come together.
I don't even know what
this thing is exactly.
I don't know what the
gatekeeping is. That's what a
lot of the discussions about.
We don't have a card. We don't
have the clubhouse. But yes,
are there a bunch of people? But by the
way, I would say that that, you know,
it obviously also includes, uh, you
know, it's as that it's white men,
which even if it was just white men,
straight white men,
and I'm not even one of them,
even if it was,
that has nothing to do
with the set of ideas.
So it's really interesting that the
same people who tell everyone else that
they're bigots and racists
and homophobia and all that,
they're the ones actually
practicing bigotry in this case.
But the group is truly diverse.
We've got ideas all over the place and
we've got men and women and gays and
straights and the rest of it.
So the best I can do is continually
be open to ideas. So by the way,
you know,
it's like two weeks ago I had a lipper
deep libertarian economics professor Don
Boudreaux from George Mason University on.
Now he happens to fall into a lot of
the ideas that I've come to really love.
I love you.
[inaudible] we did the little bit of
what the difference between a classical
liberal and a libertarian.
He's, he's into the AMCAP stuff,
which intellectually I just think it's
a fun exercise of if you want to follow
through your logic of where
small government leads,
I think it's a fun conversation to have.
So I really enjoyed that.
Then what did we do this past Monday?
Uh, we put up our interview with,
uh, who do we have on, on Monday,
man, I've been traveling a lot. Um,
Jenny Wilson Bank, you, uh, Jenny Wilson,
who's a Democrat running in a deep red
state of Utah and now obviously when it
to certain issues where
we talked about diversity,
we came to certain issues about economics.
We didn't agree and we agree.
I think at one point we actually said we
agreed to disagree and then we moved on
and it's like, I loved having
that conversation too. I,
this is what it's about.
And I think 80% of us,
I really believe this,
80% of us are in that same space and
it's the fringes on both sides that are
loud and annoying. My concern is
much more, obviously with the,
with the extremes of the left because
they have so much to do with media and
television and politics and no one has
ever called far left in the media even
though most of the democratic
establishment at this point
is pretty far left and
everyone is smeared as far right
are all right. But, um, um,
I will keep doing it and call me out if
you think I'm becoming done that in my
approach. Uh, please call me out.
I guess that that would be, uh,
putting the job back on you guys.
Uh, let's see. Uh, superchat Dave,
your thoughts on the recent
monk debate between Jordan B.
Peterson and Michael Eric Dyson. Keep
up the good work and call Shapiro, uh,
when you need a lifeline
fighting the regressives.
I've got Shapiro on speed dial. Don't
worry. Um, so I didn't see the debate yet.
I've heard a tremendous amount about it.
Obviously I've been traveling and I was
with Jordan, so I just haven't had time.
Jordan did talk about it a little bit,
but I don't want to repeat any of that
here because I just don't want to, uh,
even slightly misquote him or
anything. Um, but it sounds like, look,
it was him and Steven Fry verse
Michael Eric Dyson and um,
I think her name is Michelle Goldberg on
free speech and political correctness.
I suspect I'm going to agree more with
Stephen Fry and, and uh, Jordan. Uh,
but I will, I will check it out.
Um, all right, let's see. Uh,
I'm interested in getting in on the
conversation in the public light.
Any advice on where to start? Yeah.
Get on Youtube, man. Get on Youtube.
Just start saying what you think.
Start saying what you think.
That's what all of you guys are doing
and the more of these videos you share,
forget about what I'm doing for a second.
The more that you just in your own life,
say what you think.
That's all that I'm doing. Get out
there and do it. We need you out there.
The more they will realize that they
can't destroy us all with the mob,
that we're going to
stand up for ourselves.
We're not going to live in
fear and cowardice and that
we're not bad people and
that we're not bigots and racists and the
rest of the things that they say about
us and that we want all people,
black people and Muslim people and
Trans people and everything else to live
equally as I've repeatedly said at
the University of New Hampshire event,
although the, uh, the protesters
weren't that happy, you know,
that was a good example of what's
going on here. Actually, you know,
the protesters that came there,
they don't listen. Like I,
I could see who they were
from the beginning. Right.
You can figure it out cause they had noise
makers and they're kind of looking at
me dismissively and some,
some with just outright hatred,
which is really disturbing when you see
like a couple of young people, uh, I go,
or I suppose of any age just staring
at you with true hatred, like,
and I could see it in
them really. I could, um,
you're not going to affect those
people that much. You can't,
they have to break out of
that themselves at some point.
But all of the other people
that were there to be, uh,
to listen respectfully and hear about
ideas and engage in the conversations,
um, that's what it's all about. And
those are the people that you can get.
And I think in a weird way, the more
that these people become hysterical,
the more they're pushing people to us.
So again,
this is why whatever this group of
people is the reason we all keep getting
pushed together and the reason that a
guy on the left like Sam Harris can be
pushed this way and a guy like Ben
Shapiro or could be pushed this way,
is that what I think is in the middle is
it's not about politics, about freedom.
So when you take these two guys, I
mean, this to me is the best example.
They disagree on literally everything
from God and existential issues to taxes
and abortion and everything else.
But they're allies because they're both
fighting for their right to be able to
think freely and express
themselves freely.
And that is a beautiful thing and
that's what it's all about. Okay.
Real quick here. Uh Oh. Alright.
A lot of people still ask
them about the sweatshirt.
Rubin report.com/store we got, we
got sweatshirts, tee shirts, cutoffs.
I'll all kinds of stuff. And a while I'll
do, I'll do the pimp out one more time.
Uh, June 3rd, Tempe, Arizona
at the Tempe Improv, uh,
June 7th at the DC Improv and uh,
Seattle on June 20th at the parlor live.
Uh,
if you are watching this and you're one
of the first 20 people to buy tickets to
any of those events and the links
are right down below, uh, we,
we'll upgrade you for free to get into
the meet and greet with me after and we
can hang out and say hi
and all that good stuff.
All you gotta do is buy the ticket
and then just screenshot it,
send it to contact@rubenreport.com my
guys were on it and we'll take good care
of you. Um, what are your predictions
for the midterm election? So look,
I set a couple months,
maybe two months ago that I didn't think
it was going to be this, uh, you know,
they were talking about the blue wave
and the democratic wave and all that.
I just don't really see it.
Now you have to remember with midterms,
it's particularly hard to judge these
things properly because so few people vote
that it's only about voter turnout.
So it's a little hard,
harder to gauge, I think, than
a presidential election. Um,
what I would say is that I see a lot of
reason to think that there won't be a
blue wave. If anything,
there will be a red wave.
I think it partly has to do with
Kanye west and Candice Owens,
where I think the black community
is starting to break. I mean,
a poll came out right after
the Kanye West thing that said,
black male support for Trump doubled
from 11 to 22% within a week.
If that had been any other president
in the history of the world,
people would have gone bananas mainstream.
Basically ignore that black male support
for the president doubled in a week and
barely anybody talked about
that. So I still think, you know,
I see people all the time,
people come up to me here in la where
you can't really say you're a Trump
supporter or republican or whatever,
and they know that I'm not in,
I don't even vote for the guy. And they'll
come up to me and say, you know, Dave,
I'm so sick of this
political correctness stuff.
I mean the same stuff that was happening
before the election that has just
ramped up even more, that they're
suddenly, they're like, I kinda, I'm,
it's starting to like Trump. It's
weird. It's really weird. Um,
so I don't that there's going to be a
blue wave again. It's all about turnout,
I think will happen. Is that
within the, we'll do some shows,
obviously you're leading up to it.
And I would say that about
two weeks before the election,
that's when we'll really be able
to figure out what's going on here.
Sort of around the 20th or so of October
because that's when we'll see really
like which base is more enthused and
which is, and, and just what is, I mean,
there's so many x factors. It's hard
to figure it out this, this early on.
So all these people that pretend
they know what they're saying,
I mean they just don't.
Okay. Let's see. Um,
what single book has had the greatest
impact on changing your way of thinking or
a worldview? Well, you know,
I've been traveling with, uh,
with on liberty by John Stuart Mill,
and it's a very easy read and I would
recommend that all of you guys get it.
But I think, you know, there's
so many great books here
from so many great people,
but one book that I do reference a lot,
and I,
and I think it was formative
for me for several reasons.
So I'm in 1997 I was a,
I think I was a junior,
I was either a sophomore or junior in
college. Uh, and I saw the movie contact,
the movie with Jodie foster
and Matthew mcconaughey.
It's the only book of fiction
ever written by Carl Sagan.
And I just thought it was
the most wonderful movie
about all of the things that
I care about,
the battle between science and religion
and government and belief and all of
these things. Uh, by the way, I just
watched it a few months ago now.
It's even more relevant in a
weird way than ever before.
And it's done by Robertson Atkins,
who's brilliant,
who did a Apollo 13 and Gump and
a bunch of other stuff. Anyway,
that movie got me to read the book,
a contact,
which is also a wonderful,
uh,
but then it got me to read many other
Carl Sagan books and his last book,
which a lot of people
don't even know about.
And he actually passed away before
he finished it. And then his wife,
Andrew [inaudible],
who's also a professor at Cornell,
she actually finished the book, uh,
or at least did the last paragraph.
It's called billions and billions.
And it's funny because, uh,
Carl opens the book by saying that,
you know,
for some of you guys
that are a little older,
you may remember Johnny Carson
doing an impression of, um,
of Carl Sagan saying billions and billions
talking about stars. Apparently he,
Carl Sagan actually never
even said that phrase,
but people used to attribute
it to him all the time.
But that's why you titled
it billions of billions.
And it's just a wonderful book
on tribalism and religion.
And he talks a little
bit about, um, about,
I think he talks a little bit about
marijuana, or maybe that's in cosmos.
It's just, it's just a
wonderful book. That's his,
his true gift was being able
to communicate science and
thoughtful ideas to sort
of regular people. So if you're
looking for just something readable,
that's not like hundreds of pages,
that's going to like slam
you with complex information,
but something that can open up
some of the doors for this stuff.
Billions and billions by
Carl Sagan. I can't, I can't
recommend it. Uh, any higher.
Alright. Uh, okay.
We gotta we gotta wrap this thing
up cause I got two guests come in.
I just came in from Philly this morning.
I got, I got two guys to come in, uh,
which you'll find out about it
and the next couple of days. Uh,
so just a reminder guys, uh,
June 7th at Improv, uh, June,
uh, I'm sorry, June 7th. Yeah, no
June 3rd at Tempe Improv June 7th at
the DCM prod and June 20th at a Seattle
part of their live.
The links are right down below and if
you do buy this and you're one of the
first people to buy tickets
while you're watching this,
one of the first 20 at any
of those locations you're
getting in for the meet and
greet for absolutely free.
Just screenshot your ticket,
contacted Ruben report.com.
Anyway. All right,
I'm going to take a few minutes to
throw a little water on my face,
collect myself. We got, we got two
shows coming up today. Uh, and uh,
and then I'm,
I'm home actually for the weekend where
I'm going to try to relax a little bit
and just chill out and not spend time
online or any of that other stuff. And,
uh, and then we're back out on the
road, uh, on Tuesday we're in Houston.
And then I think the next night we're
in Dallas and then Austin and we're just
rolling out. So we're doing this basically
the rest of May, the rest of June. Uh,
we're doing a ton of it in July.
I signed on for most of those.
And then Jordan's actually
gonna continue into August. Uh,
but I'm doing the off the grid for
August thing. So I had to say no to the,
to the rest of that. And I want
to talk more about my ideas for,
for me going off the grid and I want to
challenge some of you guys perhaps to
join me on this. Uh, many of
you know, I did this last year,
were locked my phone in a safe
and didn't watch the news,
didn't do anything online, no computers,
no. Uh, no television or anything,
nothing electronic. And it was
true. It was life changing.
And I'm going to do it again in August,
and I think this year I'm going to,
I'm going to challenge you guys to
maybe try a version of it for yourself,
if not for the month, maybe for a
week or whatever you can do. Anyway,
I'm super psyched about what's going on.
Uh,
make sure you subscribe to the channel.
Of course.
Make sure you're getting the
notifications with that little bell,
but who the hell knows what's going on?
And lots of cool stuff happening
and a that is all over and out.